اعود من جديده للمسلم الكباشي وان كان قد
رصد اي تصريحات او ردود فعل او توضيحات من
قبل الدعم السريع تتعلق بهذه التطورات
نعم ازدهار لم يظهر اي توضيح هذه حرب منذ
متى هذه الحرب في نسختها التي بدات اليوم
بعد الهدنه التي استمرت 24 ساعه بدات حرب
ليس فيها كلام وليس فيها صوت الا لصوت
المدافع والرصاص وغير الى غير ذلك لم يعلن
الجيش شيئا ولم يعلن الدعم السريع شيئا في
هذه المعركه التي بدات منذ هذا الصباح منذ
نهايه الهدنه التي انتهت في السادسه من
صباح اليوم ولكن ما يميز هذه الحرب ايضا
ان الجيش كان يتخذ موقف الدفاع في الغالب
كان يستخدم بكثافه طوال هذه المعركه طوال
هذه الحرب التي بدات في منتصف ابريل
الماضي كان يستخدم سلاح الطيران بكثافه
دون ان يحرك سلاحه ثقيل او دون ان يحرك
بشكل كثيف ولكن هذه الحرب هذا اليوم هذا
اليوم ابتسم بان التحركات من قبل الجيش
السوداني كانت كثيفه من حيث استخدام
المدرعات او استخدام السيارات المقاتله
استخدام
لاول مره يحدث تحركات من جهات مختلفه
وقتحركات كثيفه من الجيش السوداني
ويستمر هذا في حربه
وشراسه عاليه في مواقع كثيره في الخرطوم
بحري في امام جسرح الفايه في الخرطوم بحري
شرقا وفي كذلك مناطق شرق النيل في الحاج
يوسف والجريف وغيرها وفي مناطق الخرطوم
بالمنطقه منطقه الجنوب الاوسط منطقه
الرميله
وغيرها من الحله الجديده
منطقه الغابه ما ذكرت بعض المراقبين من
داخل السودان اعتبروا بان ذلك يعني يعتبر
ان الجيش يبدا مرحله جديده في هذا القتال
ما درستهم في هذا الاطار فيما يتعلق
بقراءه المراقبين للتطورات الجديده
من الواضح ان الجيش بدا مرحله جديده
بالفعل لان كل الهدن التي استمرت سواء
الهدن التي توسط فيها السعوديون
والامريكان الهدن الثلاثه الاخيره او
الهدن التي سبقتها حوالي السبع هدى مختلفه
سبقت هذه الهدن الثلاثه الاخيره الراي
العام السوداني الذي يراقب هذه الحرب نحن
نراقب ايضا الراي العام في مواقعه
المختلفه وفي تفاعلاته في في الاتصال
الاجتماعي الراي العام يعتقد ان هذه الهدن
هدى عبثيه لم توصل الى نتائج سواء نتائج
عسكريه او نتائج انسانيه لاهداف التي تعلن
عنها هذه الهدن بانها اهداف انسانيه تريد
ان تفتح جسور لوصول للمساعدات الانسانيه
للمحتاجين اليها الراي العام يقول ان هذه
الهدن كانها في دائره مفرغه لم تصل الى
نتيجه وبالتالي كان هنالك الضغط على الجيش
ان يصلي في لا نتائج في هذا اما انه يدخل
في التفاوض ينهي الحرب بالتفاوض او يدخل
في حرب يعني الحرب بالح مباشره وهذا يبدو
انه بعد ان عجزت هذه الهدى من تحقيق تقدم
انها عسكري او انساني يبدو ان هذه مرحله
جديده يباشرها الجيش الان
ويحاول ان يصل الى نهايات لهذه الحرب عبر
هذه المرحله بهذا هذه المواجهه والتحركات
الكثيفه والانتقال من مرحله الدفاع تكتيك
جديد للجيش السوداني انتقال المرحله
الدفاع الى مرحله الهجوم لا ندري ما هي
النتائج الى الان ولكن المعارك على اصعد
مختلفه وفي محاور مختلفه تشتعل منذ الصباح
هذا اليوم